[Music]  all about family that was the theme of  JLo's 49th birthday this week as she  celebrated with boyfriend Alex Rodriguez  and their kids on the beach the group  shared plenty of shots from the fun  outing it's exciting but it was this  post that really turned heads  [Music]  yep that's a singer flaunting her  flawless beach body chiseled abs and all  in an itty-bitty black bikini surrounded  by her loved ones including her  ten-year-old daughter Emmie  JLo captioned the shot quote current  birthday situation yep  we're just really happy it's a it's a  it's a good time earlier in the day a  rod shared a series of sweet photos of  his girlfriend along with several loving  messages on Instagram including this one  for someone who has been about giving  everything she has 365 days a year  to our children our families the world I  hope today we can give you all the  happiness you deserve I love you  mucho he's so lovely and he's so  supportive and encouraging  you